Having a “gut feeling” isn’t just folklore,
you’re literally feeling things from your
gut, and also other organs.
Yup, it’s pretty nifty!
Hey everyone!
Amy with you on DNews today.
And I’ve got a feeling you’re going to
like this episode, and odds are my gut is
right on that.
So let’s start with the gut part of the
whole gut feeling thing.
It’s kinda gross to think about, but our
bodies are teeming with bacteria - this is
the microbiome you’ve probably heard about.
Most of those bacteria live in the gastrointestinal
tract, what we colloquially refer to as the
gut.
These bacteria regulate digestion and metabolism,
extract vitamins and nutrients from food,
and program the body’s immune system.
But there’s so much more going on!
This complex bacterial ecosystem has prompted
the gut to evolve a complex neural network
called the enteric nervous system,3 which
is so ridiculously sophisticated it’s sometimes
called the second brain.4 This network of
over 100 million neurons can even function
when it loses connection to the brain!34
And the gut-brain connection goes both ways.
Gut bacteria produce neurochemicals that regulate
basic physiological and mental processes,
influencing things like memory and mood.4And
the brain affects the microbiome; psychological
stress can suppress certain helpful bacteria
making you more likely to get sick.3
This two-way communication is part of a larger
network of inter-body talk.
The brain connecting to the gut through neural
networks, and also your ability to recognize
this connection, is an example of something
called interoception.
This is a sense of self-identity beyond knowing
what self-help books call “the real you.”
It’s the sensing of physiological signals
that originate within the body and carry information
to the brain: things like body temperature,
breathlessness, and heart rate that ultimately
give you an indication of states like hunger,
thirst, pain, and anxiety.
Whether we’re consciously aware that our
body is sending these signals, they happen,
particularly when we’re making risky decisions.
They send information to the brain and affect
the way we make decisions, so what you think
of as a “gut feeling” is actually you
responding to those subtle cues.
A recent study from the University of Cambridge
took interoception into the real world and
looked at its role in successful financial
trading, a career notorious for acting on
“gut instincts.”
The researchers measured 18 male traders’
abilities to detect subtle changes in their
physiological state by a heartbeat detection
test: how well they could count their own
resting heart rate without using a pulse point.
Admittedly this is a small sample size, but
these 18 men were better able to count their
heart rate than non-traders, and within the
group those with a higher score were also
better traders who survived longer in the
financial world, earning more money than their
less body-aware peers.
So in this case, interoceptive ability does
correlate to good decisions in a risky environment.
But correlation isn’t causation.
Just because you can pretty accurately measure
your heart rate doesn’t mean you will make
millions trading.
Other interoceptive studies have found people’s
ability to detect their heart rate increases
during times of stress, so the correlation
from traders could just be an awareness honed
from years in the industry.
But it’s also the case that professionals
practised in a field can manage their stress
better, so traders might not be experiencing
the stress reaction of an increased heart
rate.
Or it could be something totally different.
Maybe successful traders with money use their
downtime to work out, which could help develop
keener sense of body awareness.
In any case, the results do show a link between
better body awareness to interoceptive cues
and good decisions in risky environments.
So maybe there’s something to be said for
trusting your gut.
And speaking of guts, our guts do a lot more
for us than we think.
Want to know more?
Trace has a video all about how scientists
can actually program our gut bacteria to fight
harmful infections.
Check it out here.
So how many of you guys tend to go with your
gut?
Let us know in the comments below, don’t
forget to like this video, and subscribe so
you never miss an episode of DNews.